hey leave it see the friend ok see you
gotta wait whoa have it oh my god the
smell it's like cinnamon look look feel
like I'm gonna lose the mug though feel
like you guys I feel like if I hold it
here it's going to disappear you will
see you tomorrow it disappeared see how
it disappeared like that
okay believe nation welcome to a new
series that I'm starting about mail time
with Evan for people who send me stuff
and if you want to send me stuff you can
send it to the Toronto dance salsa
address will link it up in the
description below that's Nina real time
with Nina real time with everybody ND
will open your stuff first up I started
opening this this is from Aweber which
we do a bunch of google hangouts and
seminars with and they've been i've been
a client with them for ten plus years
and they sent me a bunch of stuff so
we're going to open it up look at this
box yeah Oh first up is t-shirt oh 2
t-shirts this is larvicide medium
american apparel I feel like they're
gonna do media you know I'm gonna put on
my name next up we got a hat look at
that will get the logo in there look at
that is that their local none this no
this is their mascot their logo on the
back there's no snow here in Canada you
can weird oh this one is with its a whit
pom-pom or without pom pom c with pom
pom without pom pom oh you don't want
anything more protein tonight it's
eating my protein shake up from now on
Thank You Aweber I like this next move
another t-shirt
local I like it hey american apparel
this is some quality huh american
apparel listen quality stuff to give him
a game this is large I think this feels
like a large I've shrunken down I lost
15 pounds in 30 days on my 30 day
challenge so this is the same thing but
medium oh look at this mug maybe she's
this for the protein you don't need a
mug I need a much okay you listen oh
wait that's upside down upside down yeah
look that's how the look this is how a
little bit coffee mug oh this is the top
yeah see look at that look at the lid
like it's just like a chance for coffee
mug this is a coffee mug ok so you want
yeah what do you want it so could you
sit at work he's at work you have coffee
mugs at work I like to live I feel like
I'm gonna lose the mug though oh we got
a weber stickers you got some stickers
Oh haters gonna love this one I wonder
do think if they come if he sticks it
onto something is gonna come off you
know like how how sticky are these
things I just worry but worth is gonna
end up socks hey why you'd be so she
rightly cab hey this is a medium that's
a large okay here you go okay cool fast
try I could wear this for working out
it's one for you leading media at large
you're too small where's your foot so
orangi and mine is super pale 110 I
think you're just orangi you're eating
too many carrots next package from harry
and david com mm-hmm look at the
presentation I like
that daring David Barron David we
deliver expertly crafted the light look
at that chocolate for my mouth is
watering I almost feel down myself oh
it's cookies we've got cookies cookies
we just finished our 30 day challenge so
we're allowed to eat whoa have it oh my
god the smell it's like cinnamon look
look okay look look a little
presentation look at the presentation
their cookies and then you open up to
like this feast of cookies and if you
look closely where is it where is it
right there we got the mmm kizito Oreo
something like that okay you want to
have one I want to have 10 we have put
it what's the kind 12 homemade cookies
what you stuck it on your face it's kind
of weird homestyle white chocolate
raspberry homestyle don't stick it on my
shirt hey this is I need to wear this on
my video cold temp holy cow homestyle
Double Chocolate Chunk homestyle moose
munch snack macadamia apt snickerdoodle
oh my oh one is circled peanut butter
chocolate chip Apple raisin oh wow I
have hit like a hair on my legs it hurts
ah okay don't do that holy cow put on
your your head and see how painful that
is the tick off yeah well it's good okay
I think we should share the cookies okay
my mouth is watering so much this one
this is on macadamia just down the back
I don't even remember the back story of
why harry and david sent this to me feel
like i should remember if you really buy
okay ready top this watering harry and
david handcrafted the light can't choose
no very hard to bite into well i don't
think you need more you happy that from
my phone come I need one hop on this box
may be gone tomorrow I was gonna say no
he'll disappear when you wake up
tomorrow I'm gonna hide it when you go
to work and I'm gonna finish them what
box of cookies I don't know what you're
talking about oh oh this is the honest
company stuff I love the honesty
utterance it's a spray-on it's a
spray-on i went to the honest company in
in southside la santa monica in
christopher Gavigan gave me some of
their deodorant spray and i'm a kind of
asset obsessed since i got two more
honest company the order and sprays
super excited I think we have another
cookie I was having to clean you know
hey I'm thinking out the dark chocolate
you don't like dark chocolate I might be
dark chocolate
like you have tickets oh there's two
demons okay but I want it how do you
know it start talking with the same
continent yeah right does it actually
see guys talk to be making stuff up
double chocolate that's not dark
chocolate double chocolate did you read
double chocolate chunk it doesn't say
dark chocolate anywhere you got have
another one with you you were totally I
have another one you gonna sneak it are
you gonna sneak animala me know where
I'm going to do it like an act extra or
you're gonna like sneak it in your home
or something listen this bark stays over
here yeah sparks stays with me oh yeah
anything with a Aweber sticker on it is
mine ok that's it for this mail time
thank you guys for watching first mail
time super excited you want to send me
something you want me to try it on you
want us to taste it I'm gonna do with
Nina I love food Nina loves food so
better be yummy send this stuff will try
it out okay address is going to be the
Toronto dance salsa head office leave it
to leave in the description so you can
send me more stuff thank you guys for
watching if you need to believe and
we'll see you soon